c'était une halle attendu les 800 m²
accueille depuis le 16 novembre une
vingtaine de commerçants principalement
de l'alimentaire une mise à l'abri en
cette période de froid la mairie nous a
gâté quand même vraiment d'un malheur on
arrive sur quelque chose de positif
c'est super surtout pour les commerçants
et la mort du marché et un cinoche on
peut penser d'abord aux marchands
forains qui doit apprécier d'être un peu
à l'abri par rapport aux semaines
passées
donc oui c'est une bonne initiative de
la mairie un marché perturbé ces
derniers mois après l' incendie de là à
le 31 juillet une quarantaine de
commerçants s'y retrouvent deux fois par
semaine certains d'entre eux ont vu une
baisse de leur activité
nos commerçants sont importants pour la
ville de maurepas c'est un marché qui
rayonne et qui était intercommunale et
donc je me devais en tout cas en tant
que maire et aussi avec mon équipe
d'apporter ce plus pour garantir de
passe et j'allais dire le froid l'hiver
dans de bonnes conditions
les installations seront pérennes il n'y
aura plus l'installation et la
désinstallation
donc ça c'est vraiment un gain de temps
et de confort pour de commerçants dont
quotidien dron sur le marché le mercredi
matin et le samedi matin
une consultation publique débutera en
début d'année 2020 la commune espère la
livraison de la nouvelle halle pour 2022